la question de quoi va-t-on parler
aujourd'hui et bien c'est pas compliqué
on va parler de ça me fout parce qu'à
plein de nouveautés et surtout il ya des
belles nouveautés smartphones
[Musique]
magistralement
non
régime chinois
aucun
vraiment un truc cool quand j'ai appris
que samsung avait allait sortir deux
nouveaux smartphones fin décembre début
janvier on se dit c'est vraiment cool
parce que le crs arrivés on va
probablement pouvoir les voir justement
un plat dont ginette et justement ces
trucs cool parce que là il ya trois
nouveaux sur france 4
mais réellement 3 parce qu'il ya un ace
10 version un peu plus l'être on va par
le papa se sentira pas sur le marché
français on a donc sur le marché foncé
dans la gamme acquis et le milieu de
gamme un nouveau à 51 et à 71 sont deux
produits extrêmement similaires l'un est
un peu plus piqué que l'autre d'une 404
méga succès devant une caméra de 48
capes xl ça tient dans un mouchoir de
poche raconte un peu la même histoire
avec une fois faire de la macro bon
voilà on se rapproche mais tout est
vraiment intéressant c'est de montrer un
smartphone de la gamme note un tarif
hyper intéressant par rapport aux
produits des gammes note et ça c'est
vraiment cool ça ce galaxy note 10 light
un produit que je pensais pas vos arrivé
et a effectivement des rumeurs qui
disaient qu'on pourra voir un galaxy
note 10 moins cher
clairement c'est le cas c'est arrivé et
c'est vachement bien et du coup ça me
saoule nous surprend et cherche à
élargir sa gamme pour faire face
probablement une concurrence de plus en
plus pressante et concurrence beaucoup
plus compliqué et puis à des attentes on
garde bien évidemment tout l'adn de la
gamme note avec un écran infiniti aux
percées sur le haut sans ça pas mal mais
j'ai hâte effectivement qu'on arrive
nous cacher ses petites caméras on a un
écran grandvaux magnifique
sans ce petit trou sans la bulle sans
l'encoche sens tout ça ça j'ai vraiment
hâte mais ça fait le taff sa fonction
écran infiniti aux 2 6 7 pouces full hd
plus bien évidemment un écran super
amoled avec une résolution de 2400 par
1080 pixels avec 398 pixels par pouce on
a bien évidemment ce qui fait tout l'adn
de ce produit 1 espagne en espagne qui
est connecté en espagne que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser comme sur les 9 10 et
ne disent plus pour télécommander
directement vos smartphones bouger dans
les modules ce que vous allez faire des
photos déclencher des couteaux distance
faire des présentations 1 espagne qui
garde tout son intérêt tout son adn pour
parcourir m sur un produit qui est quand
même beaucoup moins cher on a également
un trip module photo avec l'ultra grand
angle au téléobjectif
m
batterie de 4500 milliards peut encore
contenir toujours au niveau l'autonomie
est évidemment tout ça tourne sous
android 10 avec la surcouche one way
version de on a de la performance avec
un exynos 9810 si génial ram 128 g de
stockage vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 500
12 giga je pense même un petit peu plus
c'est juste qu'ils n'ont pas testé avec
d'autres cartes que celle de samsung
jusqu'à 512 mais je pense que la poussée
de quatre jusqu'à de terrain ça devrait
pouvoir passer au niveau de l'appareil
photo est ce que c'est un visage qui est
énorme on a une première caméra de 12
mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.7 on a un tel objectif avec un zoom x
2 également caméra 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 et un ultra grand angle de
12 mégapixels également qui ouvre à f
2.2 et à la vente d'une caméra de 32 me
à pixels avec une ouverture de f 2.0
world est cette fille toujours plus
optimisée et en plus avec le mode
portrait pour voir le flou
d'arrière-plan qui pour coup va être un
truc complètement logiciel puisque vous
avez pas deux objectifs mais bon ça
semble faire le taf a bien évidemment
tout ça on se testera très bientôt
le smartphone bay que je l'aurais je
testerai et je vous dirai réellement ce
qu'il en est vous pourrez vraiment voir
ce qu'il en est dans des tests mais sur
le coup je trouve assez alléchant il a
toujours espagne à 4096 le niveau de
pression différente avec une pointe de
0.7 mm et je les ai très grosse batterie
de 4500 milliards eur avec un chargeur
rapide de 25 watts de la recharge en usb
ces yeux-là d'ubuntu 5.0 on a du nfc
enfin on a quasiment tout ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur un galaxy note 10 ne
disent plus
sauf que lapointe coup on est sur une
version light d'un des gros point fort
ce problème ne cachent pas qu'ils
voudraient bien évidemment de l'écran
les écrans c'est simple succès maîtrisé
sur maîtriser extrêmement maîtrisé les
écrans sont complètement optimisé pour
lutter contre la lumière bleue
extrêmement bien calibré super couleurs
très beau contraste belle luminosité
tout ça bien évidemment on le verra on
testera mais connaissant la qualité de
sa tombe dessus
je n'ai absolument pas que ce note 10
light soit aussi un petit bijou est un
smartphone qui est à 609 l'euro qui
commence en tout cas à 609 euros
autant vous dire que pour un peu plus de
600 euros vous avez un galaxy ne disent
vous avez un gars qui ne disent light
effectivement tout sans le reverra bien
évidemment lorsque je le testerai vous
ferez la liste des différences entre les
différents modèles je vous dirai
pourquoi ce livre est intéressant par
rapport à un autre
quels avantages vous avez réellement
tirer pourquoi celui-là peut-être fait
pour vous par rapport au no 10 c par
rapport aux notes discus alors
évidemment il ya les tailles d'écran
examen de choses qui diffèrent mais ça
on va parfois très prochainement donc
vous invite dès maintenant à vous
abonner
c'est pas déjà car vous avez le bouton
qui doit être quelque part par là nous
allons tour vous cliquez vous abonnez
vous activer la cloche comme ça dès
qu'on parlera d'une 10 lite on en
parlera très prochainement comme ça vous
serez tout alors il ya eu d'autres
produits effectivement d'annoncer il ya
eu lieu à 51 et le à 71 qui sont
notamment sur le stand de cinq sous qui
est quelque part par là bas vous voyez
de planquer aussi des salades rien c'est
quoi l'idée de ces produits là l'idée
c'est déjà d'avoir un smartphone hyper
optimisé très bon aussi que dans la
photo dans le milieu de gamme avec
quatre capteurs photo à l'arrière un
écran infiniti haut avec la petite roue
directement aux votre smartphone est une
machine optimisé qui fonctionne en
milieu de gamme avec la qualité et le
savoir-faire de samsung notamment au
niveau des écrans dalle super amoled une
fois de plus ça marche bien évidemment
sur lui à 71 allez pouvoir trouver
notamment en 4h principal un capteur 12
64 médiatique secte ouvre à f 1.8 tandis
que sur le à 51 besoin d'un capteur de
46 médiatique siècle ouvre à f 2.0 dont
qui envoie captera un peu moins de
lumière ferait donc beaucoup moins de
choses en faible luminosité
voilà un petit peu en tout cas l'idée de
cette caméra principale vous avez
également un capteur qui est là pour
notre portrait pour les faits évoqués
pour gérer le flou d'arrière-plan un
mode ultra grand-angle 123° de 12
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 qui sera là
pour les photos en extérieur est ce que
vous avez besoin effectivement bien
d'abord un très grand angle pour choper
soient plaints de la midi soit un
monument et pour la première fois j'ai
pouvoir trouver un objectif qui
complètement dédiée au mode macro alors
la macro c'est rigolo je pense pas que
vous utilisiez dit lu mon commentaire je
pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup la macro
personnellement j'utilise pas trop des
jeux des smartphones qui avec la macro
j'ai essayé j'ai fait des trucs mais je
vois pas trop l'intérêt
je vais pas les photographier des
insectes je vais pas trop me rapprocher
de mes plats pour voir les détails
c'est marrant c'est là c'est une techno
qui est intégré pourquoi pas mais c'est
pas ça vient en tout cas qui va
l'enthousiasmé de plus vous pouvez donc
faire des photos une distance jusqu'à 3
cm bon pourquoi es-tu communaux dit je
pouvais faire des photos avec une caméra
de 30 2 mégapixels et dans votre petite
bulle dans votre petit rond dans votre
petit point sont en tout cas en avant et
avec un mode portrait et également pour
avoir un flou d'arrière-plan avec des
celtics sur lui à 51 d'avoir un écran de
6,5 pouces mme que sur l'a71 dans
l'heure un écran de 6,7 booth bon ça se
joue à pas grand-chose la différence
elle est vraiment minime on à la
technologie super amoled plus ça me
saoule maîtrise extrêmement bien ces
dalles donc de ce que j'ai eu sur ce
salon un retour un peu compliqué sur un
salon parce que les éclairages voilà
c'est un peu c'est pascal nu c'est pas
hyper hyper pratique mais en tout cas ça
a l'air bien marché et une fois de plus
s'est produit j'ai hâte de les tester
on pourrait prendre un nouveau but à
vous abonner comme ça en attendant très
très très prochainement l'autonomie a
l'air aussi au rendez vous à voir bien
évidemment lieu à 71 une grosse batterie
de 4500 militaires heures 4500
milliampères heures j'ai pas foule
tandis que le h 51 à une grosse batterie
de 4000 millan terreur est à noter que
le à 71 et uniquement l'a71 à un
chargeur rapide de 25 watts le à 51 à un
processeur exynos 9611 4 gigas de ram
tandis que l'a71 à un sens dragon's 730
et si jia drame dans les deux cas on à
128 go de stockage monté jusqu'à 512 je
pense un peu plus il fait plus avec une
carte microsd
les deux smartphones ont la possibilité
d'accueillir deux cartes sim est aussi
un gros focus qui a été fait au niveau
de la stabilisation super stabilisation
logiciel pour réaliser toutes vos vidéos
tout ça est bien évidemment aider grâce
à de l'intelligence artificielle bien
évidemment vous avez également un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
positionnée sous la dalle lecteur
d'empreintes digitales optique fournir
déverrouiller facilement et rapidement
vos smartphones enfin tout cas votre
smartphone en janvier plusieurs ça c'est
à vous de voir et lui à 51 sera
disponible à partir de fin janvier en
blanc bleu
nous rares tandis que bien 71 sera
disponible début février en noir argent
et bleu donc sur le papier de produits
qui ont l'air séduisant dans le milieu
de gamme ça a l'air plutôt cool je vous
ferai un test de ces produits on en
parlera très prochainement ce qui
m'intéresse par contre réellement
derrière ces deux voies la grosse
différence entre lieux à 51 et l'a71 au
niveau de la photo
au delà du côté macro ou par la
différence réellement ce qu'on va
obtenir entre capteur 64 médiatique
celle des capteurs 48 mégapixels voir
comment tu te sens réintégrer voir la
différence du niveau d'ouverture
franchement ce qui arrive à de belles
histoires à raconter de ce côté-là 60 de
samsung est effectivement toutes ces
choses là qui est intéressante et aussi
un petit robot compagnon qui était
montré qui est là dans votre maison pour
venir voir s'il ya un problème
si par exemple vous avez un chien et
qu'il avait fait qu'à midi profitent de
partout qui a mis le bazar
eh bien il le voit il va déclencher
l'aspirateur enfin c'est un espèce de
robots de la maison qui est là pour nous
faciliter la vie pourquoi pas ça peut
être rigolo on reste vraiment dans les
projets là dessus on reste un petit peu
loin
il ya bien évidemment les téléviseurs et
téléviseurs qui vont se retourner
l'idée de ces téléviseurs là si vous
voulez c'est que eh bien il ya une
grande population entre 12 et 25 ans
pour est extrêmement large qui regardent
des vidéos format paysage nocifs format
portrait beaucoup format portrait donc
l'idée c'est de venir d'abord une télé
modulaire qui s'adaptera à ses usages là
alors on est au début je sais pas si un
taux qui a vraiment bien marché mais
beaucoup voient pas donc vous avez une
télé qui l'a dynamiquement tournée de
sens prenez votre smartphone vous
tournez l'affichage tant la télé change
voulu être comme vous voulez pourquoi
pas avoir effectivement si les formats
vont changer à la télé demain ou après
demain pourquoi pas dans le futur roi
j'en sais absolument rien d'autre qu'à
ça c'est marrant la technologie de the
wall qui est toujours c'est très
impressionnant très lumineuse on peut
faire ce qu'on veut au niveau des écrans
c'est magnifique c'est samsung vous avez
l'écran et aux espaces si vous en
rappelez j'en ai déjà parlé dans
quelques années
c'est un énorme écran c'est un truc de
fou furieux
pouvez installer chez vous si vous
voulez mais ça plus dédié aux
professionnels le truc est vraiment
énorme c'est hyper compliqué à filmer
parce que faute est tellement énorme
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte la
taille que ça prend le monde qui a
devancé ouf en fait d'où peut venir en
gros faire un écran comme vous voulez
dans les dimensions que vous voulez
pouvait avoir la taille que vous voulez
pour la résolution de la boule elle
rassure vous voulez ça c'est pas du tout
fait pour un usage familial vous n'allez
pas installer la maison avant un mois
d'avoir un château avec des hauteurs de
plafond complètement dingue mais ça
montre vraiment ce qui capable de faire
samsung sont en train une certaine
vision tout cas de l'écran de l'avenir
qu'on peut faire ce qu'on veut pour du
professionnel pour l'installer où on
veut et surtout la modularité est le
truc est vraiment le moins incroyable
cette télé hui cap qui est absolument
incroyable hui car avec des bords
extrêmement fin et très bien donc là on
a un nouveau produit c'est ça qui
souffrent année c'est une aiguille cas
avec des bords qui n'existe quasiment
pas c'est le cri 950 et s7 première
écran qui as sonabel écran infinie un
peu comme les smartphones ya quelques
temps qu'ils ont déjà commencé a créé
cette mouvance
on laisse la place à l'image on retire
tout ce qui est superflu tout ce qui
peut gêner un peu l'expérience et on a
un écran qui couvre 99 fonction d'image
sur la surface totale de l'écran ou
moins à l'écran on est vraiment dans
l'immersion absolue avec en plus ce qui
est super fort c'est un voyou 5 cm
d'épaisseur
sur toute la taille du télé ont collé
collé au mur pour les hauts murs c'est
un poster 65 75 85 pouces on est sur un
truc génial quand c'est arrivé à faire
des débords aussi fort impact écologique
comment ça marche à la fois
technologique c'est à difficulté c'est
que nous nous serrons la télé on a tous
l'ensemble qui est tenu dans un chat sur
un peu dans un cadre tout est supporté
par un châssis autour la sq et des
travaillistes la manière dont la colle
et on à assembler les éléments ensemble
pour qu'ils soient tous solidaires et
qui n'est pas besoin d'avoir ce cadre
qui vient entourer les écrans et donc
pour les retirer ce qu'on appelle les bl
retirer les libéraux des bords de
l'écran un produit qui sortira sur le
marché qui est déjà ça oui on peut
acheter pour acheter comment confiera
produits comprend à un prix je crois
bien entendu acheter il sort en avril
cependant il ya eu 8 4 avant tout c'est
avant tout le monde et si alors la
ducasse et pas avec assez pour tout le
monde pourquoi c'est pour tout le monde
je suis déjà ça existe chez toi
aujourd'hui tu vas voir la lucarne
hâtives on est en france les premières à
lancer un streaming qui s'appelle
explorer oui sur kate accès à des
contenus wikio chez toi 2 on vient de
signer avec le youtube codec avait un
qui permettra d'avoir accès aux contenus
youtube sur lucas ont tout de suite
aussi tu accèdes connu huit cas et 3 il
ya plein de choses qui sont faites
notamment les consoles de jeu s'est
concentré en 2020 seront en 8k donc là
que tu veux acheter intelligent pour le
futur que tu vas me dépenser une belle
somme d'argent pour acheter un beau
téléviseur en pensant avec a finalement
certains leaders qui ont duré un bout de
temps quand on parle de personnes on est
souvent au mieux sur un teaser 35 ans
autour de 6000 euros 75 ou nantes 1,8
mille euros d'accord prix de lancement
et
en avril à cahors bien évidemment il ya
tout l'écosystème samsung la maison
réfrigérateur ça je vous en ai déjà
parlé à lee fâche détail par ma vidéo si
vous avez pas déjà vu parce que c'est
vraiment cool ça marche extrêmement bien
et une fois de plus l'écosystème samsung
s'imbriquent et y après chose à faire
avec mais on a aussi un moniteur gainey
qui hyper impressionnant très beau futur
étant je suis pas un spécialiste d'une
entorse bénigne mais en tout cas rien
calvo a joué extrêmement impression de
sens que par la qualité de la dalle la
qualité du rendu et le design global du
produit nous aussi présenté un disque
dur ssd avec lecteur d'empreintes
digitales
ce qui fait que bah si on vous le pic
est bien personne pour elle de
l'utiliser c'est plutôt pas mal pour
sécuriser ses données
pourquoi pas notamment pour les nomades
comme moi la preuve qu il ya un vrai
sens enfin plein de techno plein de
choses hyper intéressante hyper
enthousiasmante sens le temps de samsung
cette année donc bien évidemment tout ça
on en parlera en parlera beaucoup des
smartphones on parlera aussi très très
prochainement des nouveaux produits de
la gamme s qui sortira très bientôt
jusqu'à présenter en février
tous on en parlera je dois aussi rendez
vous au mwc fin février pour aller voir
toutes les nouveautés smartphones et
notamment par une route et peut-être
symptômes dont voyant une grosse actu
vous invite donc à vous abonner comme ça
vous serez tout et qui bien évidemment
arrêté qualité parce que là je parle que
beaucoup d'actionnaires du cns
il ya plein de choses qui vont arriver
dans les jours à venir donc abonnez vous
au privé la cloche comme ça on doit tout
ça en pole sur ce je vous invite à lire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous les trouvez ce
nouveau smartphone galaxy note 10 light
à 71 à 51
comment vous trouvez globalement tous
ces écrans cette télé qu l'aide
huit cas je trouve hyper impressionnante
d'un point de vue esthétique d'appareils
du design il a point de vue rendu
d'image c'est magnifique
vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire va nous on se retrouve dès
demain pour continuer à parler de nec là
pour l'instant je profite
il est quelque chose comme aller
15h17 à vegas j'ai encore un petit
rendez vous tout à l'heure si son
montage cessant soirée session travail
c'est magnifique c'est beau c'est les
gars sur soulzon boîte
[Musique]
magistrat
non
[Musique]